>> IT'S AWFUL.
CHAD, NATASHA, THANK YOU.
>>> ALSO NOW THE SCATHING
ACCUSATIONS FROM A FORMER
FACEBOOK EXECUTIVE ABOUT HOW THE
COMPANY HANDLES HATE CONTENT AND
MISINFORMATION.
FRANCES HAUGEN IS A FORMER
PRODUCT MANAGER AT FACEBOOK AND
SET TO TESTIFY BEFORE CONGRESS
TOMORROW HOW SHE SAYS THE
COMPANY PUT PROFITS OVER PUBLIC
SAFETY.
HAUGEN TELLING CBS' "60 MINUTES"
FACEBOOK KNOWS ITS PLATFORM IS
BEING USED TO SPREAD HATE AND
ENCOURAGE VIOLENCE BUT WHEN
GIVEN THE CHOICE BETWEEN THE
PUBLIC GOOD AND THE COMPANY'S
BOTTOM LINE, FACEBOOK LOOKED
AFTER ITS OWN INTERESTS.
>> ONE OF THE CONSEQUENCES HOW
FACEBOOK IS PICKING OUT THAT
CONTENT TODAY, IT IS OPTIMIZING
FOR CONTENT THAT GETS
ENGAGEMENT, A REACTION.
BUT ITS OWN RESEARCH IS SHOWING
THAT CONTENT THAT IS HATEFUL,
DIVISIVE, THAT IS POLARIZING
IT'S EASIER TO INSPIRE PEOPLE TO
ANGER THAN IT IS TO OTHER
EMOTIONS.
FACEBOOK REALIZED THAT IF THEY
CHANGE THE ALGORITHM TO BE
SAFER, PEOPLE WILL SPEND LESS
TIME ON THE SITE AND CLICK ON
LESS ADS, MAKE LESS MONEY.
>> IT'S THE BOTTOM LINE.
HAUGEN ALSO ACCUSED FACEBOOK OF
CONTRIBUTING TO THE CLIMATE THAT
LED TO THE JANUARY 6th ATTACK ON
THE CAPITOL.
SHE SAYS AFTER THE 2020 ELECTION
THE COMPANY REVERSED SOME OF ITS
OWN SAFEGUARDS AGAINST ELECTION
DISINFORMATION.
>> THEY TOLD US WE'RE DISSOLVING
CIVIC INTEGRITY.
THEY SAID OH GOOD, WE MADE IT
THROUGH THE ELECTION.
THERE WASN'T RIOTS.
WE CAN GET RID OF CIVIC
INTEGRITY.
A COUPLE MONTHS WE GOT THE
INSURRECTION AND WHEN THEY GOT
RID OF CIVIC INTEGRITY, IT WAS
THE MOMENT WHERE I WAS LIKE I
DON'T TRUST THAT THEY'RE WILLING
TO ACTUALLY INVEST WHAT NEEDS TO
BE INVESTED TO KEEP FACEBOOK
FROM BEING DANGEROUS.
AS SOON AS THE ELECTION WAS OVER
THEY TURNED THEM BACK OVER OR
TURNED THE SCIENCE BACK TO
BEFORE TO PRIORITIZE GROWTH OVER
SAFETY AND THAT FEELS LIKE A
BETRAYAL OF DEMOCRACY TO ME.
>> GROWTH OVER SAFETY.
CNN CHIEF MEDIA CORRESPONDENT
BRIAN STELTER HAS BEEN FOLLOWING
THE STORY.
THIS IS A LATEST IN THE FACEBOOK
SERIES, THEY KNOW ABOUT THE
DAMAGE, THE DISINFORMATION
SHARED ONLINE AND DON'T DO
ANYTHING ABOUT IT OR IN THIS
CASE IT SEEMS HID THAT
INFORMATION.
>> THERE ARE SO MANY COMPARISONS
TO BIG TOBACCO, TO DECADES OKAY
WHEN BIG TOBACCO COMPANIES WERE
REVEALED TO HAVE KNOWN THEIR
PRODUCTS WERE ADDICTIVE AND
DEADLY.
FACEBOOK REJECTS THOSE
COMPARISONS BUT KEEP COMING UP.
THE WHISTLE-BLOWER IS TESTIFYING
BEFORE A SENATE SUBCOMMITTEE
TOMORROW.
SHE WILL BE SPEAKING OUT ON
CAPITOL HILL AND ALREADY LINED
UP A CHANCE TO TESTIFY IN THE
UNITED KINGDOM AS WELL.
WHAT WE HAVE IN THIS SITUATION
IS AN INSIDER SAYING WHAT SO
MANY OF FACEBOOK'S OUTSIDE
CRITICS HAVE BEEN SAYING FOR
YEARS.
NOW YOU HAVE SOMEONE ON THE
INSIDE WHO IS WORKING AS A
PRODUCT MANAGER WORKING ON
MISINFORMATION TRYING TO COMBAT
FACEBOOK'S PROBLEMS.
SHE CAME TO CONCLUDE FACEBOOK
WAS NOT GOING TO DO SO, THAT THE
SITUATION WAS GETTING WORSE AND
AS YOU SEE ON SCREEN THERE, HER
LAWYERS HAVE FILED EIGHT
COMPLAINTS, AT LEAST EIGHT
COMPLAINTS WITH THE SEC.
OF COURSE THE GOVERNMENT AGENCY
THAT REGULATES THE FINANCIAL
MARKETS SO WHAT SHE IS CHARGING
IS THAT WHAT FACEBOOK SAYS IN
PUBLIC IS A LIE COMPARED TO WHAT
SHE KNOWS IN PRIVATE.
SHE'S ALSO THE PERSON WHO LEAKED
THE DOCUMENTS TO THE "WALL
STREET JOURNAL" AND PROVIDED ALL
THIS EVIDENCE FACEBOOK KNOWS
ABOUT THE FLAWS OF ITS
PLATFORMS.
I INTERVIEWED NICK CLEGG ONE OF
THE TOP SPOKESPEOPLE FOR
FACEBOOK AND HE ADVANCES THE
ARGUMENT NO SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORM IS PERFECT BUT WE ARE
TRYING OUR BEST.
HERE IS A PART OF WHAT CLEGG
TOLD ME.
>> THIS IS A GOOD EXAMPLE OF THE
COMPANY DOING WHAT I HOPE PEOPLE
WOULD EXPECT WE SHOULD DO, NOT
PRETENDING THAT EVERYTHING IS
PERFECT ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
IT ISN'T.
RESEARCHING WHERE MINORITY OF
INSTANCES, WHERE IT'S NOT
WORKING OUT RIGHT FOR PEOPLE AND
TRYING TO FIX IT AS MUCH AS WE
CAN ON OUR OWN APPS.
>> MOST PEOPLE HAVE A GOOD
EXPERIENCE ON FACEBOOK AND
INSTAGRAM AND FOR THE PEOPLE WHO
DON'T, WE'RE TRYING TO IMPROVE
THAT, FIX THAT.
THE BROADER QUESTION THOUGH WHEN
THERE'S A PRODUCT SO ADDICTIVE
THAT'S WARPING OUR BRAINS AND
MINDS THAT IS USED BY BILLIONS
OF PEOPLE, IS IT BIGGER THAN
ANYONE CAN CONTROL, HAS THE
MONSTER BECOME TOO BIG FOR
FACEBOOK TO CONTROL?
>> IT'S AN IMPORTANT QUESTION.
BRIAN STELTER, APPRECIATE IT AS
ALWAYS.
LISA BANKS IS AN EMPLOYMENT
WHISTLE-BLOWER ATTORNEY
REPRESENTED FORMER CAPITOL
POLICE CHIEF AND DR. RICK
BRIGHT.
IT'S GOOD TO HAVE YOU WITH US
THIS MORNING.
BASED ON YOUR EXPERIENCE, WHAT
HAPPENS NEXT HERE?
>> WELL, I THINK THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER WILL CONTINUE TO
EXPOSE WHAT SHE BRIEFS TO BE
WRONGDOING AND THROUGH CONGRESS
AND THE SEC AND ALL LIKELIHOOD
CONTINUE DOING IT THROUGH THE
MEDIA AS WELL.
>> DID FACEBOOK, BIG PICTURE
HERE, WHICH HAVING THIS
INFORMATION INTERNALLY AND NOT
SHARING IT, INCLUDING WITH
FILINGS WITH THE SEC, DID
FACEBOOK BREAK ANY LAWS HERE?
>> IT'S POSSIBLE.
THAT WOULD BE THE BASIS OF HER
SEC FILING, WHAT FACEBOOK SAID
TO CONGRESS, REGULATORS AND THE
PUBLIC WAS FALSE AND MISLEADING
TO INVESTORS AND THAT CAN BE A
VIOLATION OF SEC LAWS AND
REGULATIONS SO THAT IS THE BASIS
OF HER SEC FILING.
>> THERE WERE A NUMBER OF
FILINGS BEFORE THE SEC, SHE'S
SET TO TESTIFY BEFORE CONGRESS
TOMORROW.
IN TERMS OF PROVIDING THE
DOCUMENTS TO THE MEDIA, IS THAT
GENERALLY WHAT WOULD YOU ALSO
ADVISE A CLIENT TO DO TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS INFORMATION GETS
OUT?
HOW IMPORTANT AND HOW WISE IS
THAT PART OF WHAT WE'RE SEEING?
>> WELL, IT'S RISKY TO DO IT FOR
SURE.
WHEN YOU REVEAL INFORMATION TO
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES, THE SEC,
CONGRESS, THAT'S GENERALLY
PROTECTED.
WHEN YOU GO TO THE PRESS, WHEN
YOU GIVE "THE WALL STREET
JOURNAL" THOUSANDS OF DOCUMENTS,
THAT'S A LITTLE RISKIER, BUT
SOMETIMES IT'S NECESSARY.
BECAUSE A WHISTLE EMPLOYEER IS
TRYING TO EXPOSE SERIOUS
WRONGDOING IN THE HOPES THAT
CHANGE CAN BE AFFECTED.
AND IF YOU GO TO THE SEC OR
SOMETIMES EVEN TO CONGRESS,
YOU'RE NOT ASSURED THAT
INFORMATION WILL GET OUT.
SOMETIMES THE MEDIA IS THE BEST
WAY TO TO THIS AND OFTEN IS A
NECESSARY STEP FOR
WHISTLE-BLOWERS.
>> WE SAW THAT IN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, CONCERNS THAT,
FOLLOWING THE INTERNAL PROCESS
COULD BE QUASHED BY OUTSIDE
PARTISANS.
ARE WHISTLE-BLOWER LAWS WRITTEN
TO SUFFICIENTLY PROTECT
WHISTLE-BLOWERS LIKE THIS FROM
CRIMINAL PROSECUTION?
>> DEPENDING WHERE THEY BRING
THE INFORMATION.
SHE'S PROTECTED GOING TO THE SEC
FOR EXAMPLE.
SHE MAY NOT BE PROTECTED GOING
TO "THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" AND
IT'S ENTIRELY CONCEIVABLE THAT
FACEBOOK WILL BRING SOME SORT OF
CIVIL ACTION AGAINST HER, BREACH
OF NONDISCLOSURE AGREEMENT OR
MISAPPROPRIATION OF TRADE
SECRETS OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
BUT JUST BECAUSE THEY CAN
DOESN'T MEAN THEY SHOULD.
>> RIGHT, THEY MAY MAKE THEIR
OWN JUDGMENT ABOUT PUBLIC